Замість кіосків - новий сквер,
а замість великої парковки - пішохідна зона.
Так у 2017 році розпочався експеримент на Контрактовій площі у Києві.
Від автомобілів тоді звільнили не лише площу, але й вулицю Сагайдачного.
І це лише невелика частина змін, які мали відбутися на Подолі.
Та схоже, проєкт під загрозою.
Шестеро киян вирішили, що закриття автомобільного руху
обмежує їхні права, подали позов до суду
та виграли його.
Тепер автівки можуть знову заполонити Контрактову.
Ця новина неабияк обурила громадського активіста
та борця за пішохідний Київ Віталія Селика.
Я дуже злякався, адже уявив, як на цій найстарішій площі Києва
знову буде грандіозний безкоштовний паркінг,
де неможливо пройти і де смердить бензином.
Де постійно проїжджають автомобілі і  просто страшно вийти.
Разом з іншими небайдужими він записав відеозвернення
до Київської міської ради з вимогою захистити площу.
Пішохідіні зони є візитівками всіх міст
Адже йдеться не лише про нову пішохідну зону Києва,
але й про грандіозний проєкт реконструкції Подолу,
який існує ще з 2013 року.
Згідно з ним, Контрактова площа входитиме до території
великої туристичної зони Києва і з'єднається з Андріївським узвозом,
Алеєю Художника, Володимирською гіркою.
Антон Олійник - один з 10 архітекторів, який працював над проєктом
пішохідної Контактової площі та вулиці Сагайдачного.
Концепція під назвою "Київська вітальня" перемогла на архітектурному конкурсі.
Вона передбачає комплексне оновлення площі -
оновлення скверів і Подільського пасажу, облаштування транспортного хабу,
створення численних зон відпочинку.
Постійне місце суперечки - це вулиця Сагайдачного.
Чи бути їй автомобільною чи пішохідною.
І тому в проєкті з'явились дерева, щоб остаточно визначитись:
так для кого ця вулиця - для людей чи машин?
Антон Олійник занепокоєний рішенням Окружного суду.
Адже добре пам'ятає, як п'ять років тому нелегко прошховхували
проєкт з перетворення площі на пішохідну.
На папері така ідея існувала в КМДА ще за часів Олександра Попова.
Але вона, мабуть, так і залишилася б на папері, якби не іноземні експерти.
GIZ  допомагали адміністрації
донести думку, що це дуже важливо зробити.
І що місто, яке має 4 мільйони людей,
повинно мати пішохідну площу
і хоч одну пішохідну вулицю.
Це нормально.
Це треба і вони тоді казали:
ви спробуйте і побачите,
що це може дати поштовх покращенню всього міста.
І це запустить урбаністичний рух.
На той час радницею при КМДА працювала німкеня Катаріна Ґеорґе.
Вона ж здійснювала фахову координацію інтегрованого розвитку Подільського району.
Нині вже майже рік, як завершила роботу в проєкті,
тож про рішення суду щодо можливого повернення автомобілів на Контрактову площу
дізнається від Deutsche Welle. І не була здивована.
Автомобілісти зазвичай мають сильне лобі,
і їхнє домінування в міських районах також значне.
Машини просто займають більше місця, а отже хочуть більше влади.
Вони відштовхують пішоходів чи велосипедистів з міського простору.
Я три роки жила на Контактовій і добре знаю це місце.
Я знаю площу як влітку, так і взимку.
І з численними ярмарками, які там відбуваються.
Але також і те, яка вона мертва, взимку чи коли там не проходять жодні виставки.
Тоді ти помічаєш, яка вона велика і невпорядкована.
Я думаю, що незначна частина площі, все ж таки може витримати транспорт,
аби поєднувати дорожню мережу, як це і планується згідно з запропонованою концепцією
У мерії на рішення Окружного суду поки відреагували лише публічною заявою.
Наразі готують апеляцію.
Окрім того, каже заступник мера Києва Валентин Мондриївський,
проводять розслідування  - хто стоїть за шістьма невдоволеними автомобілістами
Відхилятися від плану реконструкції Контрактової тут не збираються.
Фахівці над ним працюють, вивчають, які матеріали мають бути застосовані,
які об'єми, скільки це буде коштувати, які види робіт та їхня вартість.
Ми отримаємо, сподіваюсь, результати найближчими тижнями
від державної експертизи проєкту,
і у вересні ми видамо міське розпорядження
про затвердження проєкту
остаточної реконструкції Контрактової площі і вулиці Сагайдачного.
За оптимістичними планами, завершити реконструкцію Контрактової площі
хочуть до кінця 2022 року.
Утім, швидкість реконстукції залежить не лише від наявних грошей у бюджеті,
але й від того, як складеться доля Гостинного двору,
що в самому центрі площі, каже активіст Віталій Селик.
Він входить в робочу групу при Фонді держмайна,
яка опікується будівлею та її поверненням в державну власність.
На сьогодні у Гостинного двору немає фінального проєкту,
як його будуть відбудовувати.
А від цього залежить, які інженерні комунікації будуть до нього проведені:
це вода, газ, опалення.
А вже від цього залежить, як їх будуть прокладати,
так і будуть перекопувати площу.
І якщо площа буде зроблена,
коли будуть вестись комунікації до Гостинного Двору, коли його будуть відбудовувати,
то це може викликати незадоволення киян,
які бачили нову відремонтовану площу і знову тут перекопувати.
Згідно з опитуванням, яке робили аналітики центру CEDOS,
майже 82% подолян хочуть бачити площу пішохідною.
Такої ж думки і перехожі, з якими поспілкувалася DW.
Класно було б зробити її повністю пішохідною,
більше зелених площ, зелених зон.
Для дітей щось, бо немає особливо куди з дітьми ними вийти.
Контрактова площа має бути для людей як пішохідна зона,
щоб люди могли відпочивати, більше гуляти,
тому що таких місць в Києві, де можна прогулятися, досить мало.
Київ більше для автомобілістів, а не пішоходів.
Думаю, що треба з цим працювати і відвоювати назад.
Моя позиція така:
Поділ - це старий район Києва,
і інфраструктурно треба вирішувати питання щодо транспортних розв'язок.
Якщо проєкт розвитку міста
буде передбачати адекватні необхідності автомобілістів,
то площу дійсно можна виділити як суто пішохідну зону.
Контрактова площа нині є великим транспортним вузлом.
Сюди з'їжджаються автобуси, трамваї та маршрутки з усіх куточків Києва.
Автори проєкту "Київська вітальня" хочуть зберегти її транспорту значимість,
разом з тим мріють відновити її втрачену історичну та культурну цінність.
Адже, на відміну від інших європейських міст,
у Києві досі немає єдиної великої пішохідної зони,
яка б приваблювала туристів та містян, а отже й бізнес.
Крім того, успішна реконструкція Контрактової площі
могла би бути прецедентом і для інших українських міст,
історичні центри яких поки що запруджені автівками.